the Joe Rogan experience that's what was
so weird about working at playboy was I
got there right when they went not nude
like one minute I was like McDonald's
being like we're not serving fries
anymore sorry guys it was like new coke
like what yeah why would you [ __ ] with
coke so that was a weird time and then
it was a lot of transition but just
writing for men waking up to the fact
that there was this culture war and then
writing for men at a time when it was
like anti men right I didn't realize
that it happened to either I was like
still singing this is a man's world like
in my mind and then suddenly I was like
oh there's a good there's a sex war
going on - I got the idea behind me -
like I was also sexually abused me too I
didn't get the times up like the other
thing at times up times up for what like
what is the time up for it's such a
common phrase like it's so weird when
the guys like I can't wait to see you
and I'm always like hashtag me too cuz
now it's become a joke yeah I know
there's been enough Asia Argento is
enough you know hypocrites enough for
the crazy one but it is important you
know because I mean circling back to
what happened to me last week and in my
young like childhood it's important that
these the you know I see that woman that
I that the 19 year old as my hero but
also the culture is more supportive of
her going and saying something and it
was not 20 years ago at all so that is
progress you know that's definitely
progress yeah is that but progress is
not clean no progress comes in these
ways
knocks rocks over rocks over pylons and
then everybody rebuilds and then figure
out where the [ __ ] the ocean line is now
you know the shore line moves everything
moves and that's been the weird thing is
that it's I I you know I was joking the
other day that I'm like
you know sometimes something will happen
with Trump and I'll be like alright
that's it
you know like sign me up for the
resistance I'm going to be marching in
the treats it's in the streets in the
minute they're like uh yeah and what's
your gender I'd be like i'm evade that
I'm just out I'm out
they them I have a friend whose
daughters they are they she calls
herself they well I would be you know
that's the other thing too is that you
you latch on to these things when you're
a kid of course you're totally gonna be
ripe for having that happen to you don't
for sure ya know you're gonna have like
tuve them's babies they call baby baby
it people are raising their kids as baby
I just say let them decide what they
know I don't push them in any one way
ever
these kids are gonna be so [ __ ] [ __ ]
Disney ride that was a weird thing when
I was working on the this is also
another weird moment I'm having right
now because I listen to so much of your
podcast when I was trimming weed and
anyone who's trim weed knows you do it
for like 13 hours at a clip and go crazy
and somewhere in an alternate timeline
I'm trimming we listening to me this was
that that whole culture and it's so
funny because the way those kids revolt
like the way they rebel all the like
hippie kids who grew up with like their
parents on acid losing them if you know
festivals and [ __ ] and the Burning Man
kids like one of my friends she joined
the army I'm like yeah this is what
happens that's how they rebel the kids
they grew up with all this crazy [ __ ]
they're like yeah I'm gonna be I'm
joining the D [ __ ] a mom that's what
I'm doing yeah yeah if your parents are
drug addicts he becomes sober and a
marathon runner yeah yeah so your kids
are gonna be like you know it's they dad
[Applause]